British artist David Hockney said he was
drawn to California by the sunshine me
too David Hockney his time there also
set him on a path to creating paintings
with very vibrant colors tonight one of
his works called portrait of an artist
pool with two figures is expected to set
a record at the auction
CBS this morning Saturday co-host
Anthony Mason saw the painting up close
he's here to share his unique history
Anthony didn't even see you come in good
morning Gail this painting is considered
by many to be David Hockney's greatest
work it was featured in a blockbuster
exhibition that toured London Paris in
New York's Metropolitan Museum last year
now it's poised to make the 81 year old
Hockney the most expensive artist alive
[Music]
workers carefully uncrated the Hockney
masterpiece last week at Christie's
auction house in Rockefeller Center
portrait of an artist who'll with two
figures will be the centerpiece of
tonight's post-war and contemporary art
sale says Christie's Alex Rotter the
estimate on this painting eighty million
dollars which would set a record which
would set a record not just for a work
by Hockney but for any work by a living
artist it would shatter the record set
by Jeff Koons
balloon dog which sold for fifty eight
point four million dollars in 2013 why
do you think you've been so popular over
the years I like to think it may be the
space in the pictures mm-hmm you don't
know why things become memorable if
there was a formula for them there'd be
a lot more about we talked to the artist
two years ago in his studio in Los
Angeles a long way from the town where
Hockney was raised Bradford in northern
England you've described the place you
grew up in this is kind of dingy dingy
well it was Gothic gloom so so where did
your sense of color come from well
probably California the moment I came
here the color took off and your
fascination with pools really began
because of California it's always an
interesting thing how do you pain Walt
how do you penned something Chung's
patterns portrait of an artist is
perhaps Hockney's most famous pool
picture it's also the only one to
include his other most prominent theme
the double portrait there's a story
behind this picture this one is actually
a very personal story because it's about
his love and his lost love or his loved
love that he's about to lose
the story is told in the 1974 film a
bigger splash which captured hockney
working on a first version of the
painting which he'd later abandon and
destroy and then showed him
photographing his estranged lover
Peter Schlesinger for the second
painting which he finished although the
British pop artist became popular in
America for a long time art historians
were unsure where to place Hockney and
the market took a long time to come
around because he found his real his
language just when he moved to America
and then was seen in a funny way in the
context of American paintings he didn't
seem to fit anywhere he didn't fit
anywhere but at 81
Hockney who's still at work may have
lived long enough to become the priciest
living painter you just go on till you
fall over that your plan I'm still a
smoker I mean I just go on and one day
I'll fall over yeah I don't mind I'll
try not to fall over here tonight's
winning bid is expected to more than
double the previous record paid for a
David Hockney painting which was twenty
eight and a half million dollars at
Sotheby's auction house that was just
earlier this year I love how he said he
loves the the wiggly lines that's what
my whole you make he spent so much time
trying to figure out how to how to paint
water yeah you can't capture that in the
picture you know yes but he managed to
it's like those paintings of
particularly of Los Angeles are so
iconic now it's that's what you're
seeing in the market and it's a nice big
painting to go well over the sofa Norah
right I can take up a whole wall this
has nothing to do with your story today
but there's a story in the news about
men and beards yes and it says that men
that have the light stubble beard yes
are considered the most popular these
days even more than clean-shaven so
you're very much on trend okay thank you
wear it well okay you're welcome the
jury's out on that one but we'll see
you're welcome to bags always get a
compliment here today
love you we tell it like it is okay like
we see thanks Anthony